you've seen a lot of people leave their
body I'm sure oh yeah so do you believe
in ghosts no not at all no but I've seen
some weird stuff I mean I mean death is
a very I mean one thing I realized when
I started practicing internal medicine
is like oh okay when everybody else all
the Specialists and everybody are done
with them they send it back to us to die
but I've seen some weird stuff I've seen
some things like you know this one guy
was dying actively and he was delirious
and you know sort of encephalopathic we
call that he all of a sudden at like 11
o'clock in the morning sat up in bed and
went I'm an appointment with Jack Smith
at one hand don't let me forget and he
went back into this delirium and his
family reported this to me and they go
Jackson it's been dead for years it's so
weird 110 guy died one at one time yeah
right when he said right when he said he
had the appointment
I always got this appointment